no means no that's another one no means
no
it's like no it doesn't all right
look look no means no no that means no
all right but no
stop it what are you doing oh my god
you're being so bad stop it
no yeah that's not a [ __ ] no
that means i want to do it but i'm
afraid you're going to judge me
so i'm just going to make it look like
it was your idea so you don't figure out
that i've already performed this act
with 40 other [ __ ] people
right but then
then you go to court and you get a bad
read and there's some guy reading it uh
your honor she said no
stop it what are you doing you're being
so bad
yeah and you just sent me like she
didn't [ __ ] say it like that
she didn't say it like that
so i'm sick of obama's wife
yeah this isn't some republican
rant either it's just kind of first
ladies in general
you know i don't know what it is all
throughout my life with each presidency
like these first ladies they've just
gotten more and more like like uh like
chatty you know more and more
chiming in like leaning into the frame
spitting out their ideas it's just like
why are you talking right
you weren't elected shut up
your husband's not running a lemonade
stand here he's running the country
you don't just chime in
let me guess is this considered sexist
it is why okay you just nodded there
lady let me ask you this
all right let's say you had a leak in
your house okay you call a plumber up
he shows up and he goes yeah i think the
league's coming from the upstairs
bathroom we need to shut it off
but then all of a sudden his wife walks
in who isn't a plumber
and they go yeah you know i'm actually
taking care of any attack wouldn't you
be like with all due respect
shut the [ __ ] up i need a plumber
in this moment
i'll extend an olive branch here all
right at some point
there's gonna be the first female
president right
exactly which means at that moment
you're gonna have the first male first
lady
right and when that happens that dude
needs to shut his trap i don't want to
hear a word out of him
i want to hear from the president you
sir go do some first lady stuff
all right go get yourself some gloves
that go up to your elbows
smile and nod during speeches
go put your own flair redecorating the
white house
right which leads you to michelle obama
right
now she's sitting there holding up those
hashtags from that hashtag bring back
our girls
remember that it's like it blew my mind
it's like why are you showing me that
i'm a stand-up comedian like what am i
gonna do
to get those girls back why don't you
look across the dinner table it's like
you see that guy
that is the leader of the free world
tell them to pick up a phone
call some navy seals and solve it what
am i going to do
show up with the sharpened mic standard
michelle said to bring her back
so let's talk uh let's talk white women
here shall we
let's talk white women white women
you're amazing amazing your
accomplishments over the last few years
i got to tell you the way white women
somehow hijack
the woke movement generals around the
world should be analyzing this
just to refresh your memory the woke
movement was supposed to be about people
of color
not getting opportunities the at-bats
that they deserved
finally making that happen and it was
about that for about eight seconds
and then somehow white women swung their
gucci booted feet
over the fence of oppression and stuck
themselves
at the front of the line i don't know
how they did it
i've never heard so much complaining in
my life from white women
my name is with my suv and my heated
seats
you have no idea what it's like to be me
trash and white guys the nerve where's
the camera the nerve
of you white women let me
listen i don't want to speak ill of my
[ __ ] here okay
i don't but let's let's go back in
history here okay
you guys stood by us toxic white males
through centuries
of our crimes against humanity you
rolled around in the blood money
and occasionally when you wanted to
sneak off and hook up with the black
dude
if you got caught you said it wasn't
consensual
yeah that's what you did that's what you
did
so why don't you shut up sit down next
to me and take your talking to
[Laughter]
thank you i will get married you know
i was making that i'll definitely get
married someday you know i you know i
love women and everything i'm just
finding i'm not like compatible with
them you know what i mean
if they just feel that like women have
like too much energy for me you know
what i mean like you can't have a day
off when you have a girlfriend you don't
notice that
it's almost like they see that open day
they're like oh my god let's go fill it
up with [ __ ]
no then they just come at you with one
horrible idea after another
horrible ideas like you want to make
some sandwiches and go to the park
you want to go to the container store
get some containers for your t-shirts
this is the worst one there we get this
one you want to go to brunch
you want to go to brunch on sunday and
inside you're like [ __ ]
no but you can't say that right
you got to keep them happy so what do
you do you agree like yeah let's go to
brunch
what a great idea why would you want to
sleep in on a sunday when you can go pay
18
for eggs now you're thinking
now you're thinking then we can sit
around to listen to your friends have
moronic conversations about the eggs
like
is that pesto is that
pesto in your omelette oh it's asparagus
it's asparagus i thought it was pesto
oh you just want to flip the whole
[ __ ] table over
it's horrendous
i'm trying to learn to pick my battles
when i date girls i usually argue with
women all the time man i'm stupid like
that
you know like i dated this girl one time
she was like really into like women's
issues
so we used to always have these dumb ass
arguments so one time she came up to me
she goes okay explain this to me bro
why does a guy make more an hour to do
the exact same job huh
i go i'll tell you why because in the
unlikely event that we're both on a
titanic and it starts to sink
for some [ __ ] up reason you get to
leave with the kids and i have to stay
[Applause]
hey that's why i get the dolomar now
no think about it if there's a house
fire it's always women and children
first
i got to stand there with like the back
of my shirt on fire going let's go
people let's go let's go
so that's how i look at it no it's a
dollar an hour surcharge
that if something [ __ ] up happens
either i can't leave
or i gotta like get in the way of it to
give you a head start like rabid dog run
honey
one mississippi two mississippi
you hear a bump in the night i gotta go
check it out like yes he does have a
knife
anytime there's a hostage situation who
do they negotiate for first
well at least let the women and children
go
well what about me
bullets hurt me too why the [ __ ] do i
gotta stay in the vault
no that's my point man where are all the
feminists in those situations you know
what i mean you can't find them
there are no feminists in a house fire
that's a guarantee
you could take the most hardcore
feminist some chick right in your face
like he showed me this take down a [ __ ]
little short little haircut the whole
nine yards right
second those flames break out she's
gonna twist those little hairs into
pigtails no i'm just a girl
i want to go play jump rope
and leave you standing in a burning
house like you're not flammable
you know but i'm not i'm not a dick
though
i'm not i'm not saying i think a woman
should make a dollar less an hour to do
the same job all i'm saying
is if you're going to make what i make
when the boat sinks you better be
standing right there next to me listen
to that guy play the cello
then you get the corner office you get
all the benefits or whatever
i was going back and forth with somebody
um
this morning an east coast friend of
mine who hadn't talked to in a while how
you enjoy being a dad and blah blah blah
blah blah
and then she hits me up with the whole
hey i'm turning 50 this year
i am not happy about it i said yeah i
turned 50 last year she goes how is
turning 50 for you
you know she goes you're a guy you
probably don't care it's much harder for
a woman especially with our careers
oh did i have fun with that you know
i just wrote back
[Applause]
jesus [ __ ] christ you know what i
mean
white women complaining is one of the
funniest it's like you got a [ __ ]
house and a beautiful family what is the
[ __ ]
so much harder for me you're gonna
outlive me by six to eight years
so me turning 50s like me turning like
56 57
58. you know hear me complaining you
know
you never hear me complain on this
podcast this is nothing but positivity
rainbows and [ __ ] unicorns
um yeah i love that [ __ ]
it's harder for it's harder for women to
go to the gym it's harder for us to lose
weight well then [ __ ] work harder
you know everybody's different oh is
that where it's harder you know what you
know it's harder for me
uh uh trying to get some woman to pay
the cover charge and buy me drinks
you know it's harder for me to divorce
court uh outliving you
i mean it balances out ladies
getting child support yeah that's harder
for me because i'll be the one paying it
then all of a sudden it costs 900 grand
a month to raise a [ __ ] two-year-old
right
i i just don't understand the constant
complaining by white women
okay you're white you live in america
shut up okay
wait till the other problems are solved
and then we'll get to you you're at the
meat counter
your number isn't up yet wait your turn
all right wait your turn abigail
do you know how much hard it's so much
easier for you to go to chat
it's not easier men's lives are harder
because we have to live with you guys
[Laughter]
oh man i want to become friends with a
lesbian couple and i want to like
be friends with like the the the chick
in the relationship that's gotta handle
more of the dude [ __ ]
you know because you know opposites
attract and i would think even like in
the lesbian community there's gonna be
somebody you know who's out there
swinging the axe getting the [ __ ]
firewood
while the other one's in there making
the muffins that's the lesbian i want to
talk to
right into my podcast please you know i
want to know if if those lesbians
on average die sooner
than than than the the dainty lesbian
you know
the lesbian who's got to go out on the
[ __ ] roof and adjust the [ __ ]
directv
satellite [ __ ] thing in the middle of
the [ __ ] rain
that's who i want to that's who i wanna
hear from that's the study i would be
doing